number one New York Times bestselling
author that's Harlan Coben is famous for
his suspense novels more than 70 million
copies of his books have been sold
worldwide they are published in 43
different languages so what does he do
he writes another one number 31 his
newest novel is called runaway it
follows a Wall Street financial adviser
as he searches for his missing daughter
ultimately he finds himself immersed in
a dangerous world of crime and murder -
Harlan Coben joins us at the table once
again first on CBS this morning we
always like it when you come back thank
you Thank You Harlan when I was getting
dressed this morning I said you know
what I'm gonna dress like the girl but
this is the thing I want to read the
first line of the book because I love
first lines of books Simon said on a
bench in Central Park and strawberry
feels to be more precise and felt his
heart shatter so I'm thinking was he
attacked did he have a heart attack what
happened to him and the reason why I
liked the first line in that book is
because that's actually what you did yep
your heart didn't shatter in Central
Park West Strawberry Fields and I was
watching one of those street musicians
mangle a John Lennon tune as you will
hear all the time I was like that was my
kid what if that was my kid in missing
six months that's a book opens he sees
his kid and we tries to rescue her
everything goes wrong
yeah and she just looks like a homeless
person right clearly strung out on drugs
yeah you know that's why it's hard
chattered to says he sees its daughter
anyway but this is the thing about this
book because you touch on genealogy
websites viral videos drug addiction and
adoptions do you just take what's going
on in the world and figure out let me
throw it in a book in some way because
it really does hit on all a lot of
things that are happening today I kind
of do I don't do a lot of research by
see what's going on all these things I
don't do a lot uh-huh I mean I did do
one of those genealogy DNA tests because
I had to and I was really excited
because I saw I had a first cousin and I
checked and it was my first cousin so
that was really kind of disappointing
but no big surprises in my own life but
you know be boring in your real life
like Bruce wah so you can be violent and
original and your work to quote flow
there laugh libéré so yeah that's how
the book Starla
wanted to grip you right away I wanted
to get you interest rate and I wanted a
lot of things that we can relate to you
know the dog in the book is named Laszlo
that's your own dogs apparently other
members of your family any similarities
in this know my four kids I four kids
read the book right away and then they
all said oh I bet you he based the
drug-addict one on you the wife and the
book is a pediatrician and your wife is
a PDS there's a similarity is that the
kids I thought whose kids yeah it's my
wife there's a pediatrician at Columbia
Presbyterian up in New York yes but
that's sort of that I don't know how
similar she is to Ingrid but all of all
writing you try to not write what you
know but it always is what you know
that's always your life and you're
saying but don't overthink it and in
this case yeah well you don't think you
don't you read it you can do it ever you
want your churning books out so quickly
even compared it to pregnancy your words
not mine
chronic just to explain I said that it
takes nine months the best part is the
idea wink wink wink and at the end you
feel like you have a dump truck parked
on your bladder and you just want the
dang thing out that's what I mean by
it's kind of like pregnancy and so what
keeps you going though with all of these
stories have you ever been again
certainly you've never no no I I do
actually every day I do it's a struggle
every day every day I feel insecure
every day I go through all those things
writers do you just have to fight
through it this is the thing about this
book there twist upon twist upon twist
that even right down to the very last
page you still leave us but you killed
off one up I won't say the character
okay good please killed off one of the
characters here and I was so
disappointed that you did that when you
started the book you said you mad at me
before but I was really irritated but do
you know the beginning the middle in the
end or are you sort of doing it as you
go along I know the beginning in the end
so the last was fooled you right yeah
and I hope it lingers yes so and makes
you think so I know that last twist
before I start so it helps it's like
making a journey from you know here in
New York to LA I may go route 80 I may
go via the Suez Canal or stop in Tokyo
but I'll end up in LA for readers sake
please say chronically pregnant yeah
always good to have you here fun at the
table too and runaway is on sale today
you can buy it in any Airport bookstore
I see it's a Harlan Coben books
everywhere all right